you know what um Tucker Carlson is in
trouble for saying some some bad things
he said some bad things on a radio show
a long time ago but I think that he just
has a different experience in the use of
words that's all he just said that's all
it is that's the excuse that Nancy
Pelosi offered for Elon omar on Friday
those were her exact words she said that
no you know Omar isn't anti-semitic she
just she has a different experience in
the use of words which is just that
might be my favorite politician II thing
that any politician has ever said it's
certainly the most politician thing that
any politician has ever said it's it's
so good that it made probably made Bill
Clinton jealous like Bill Clinton heard
that inside well why did I think to ever
say that that's a good one
it depends on what the definition of is
is that's pretty good but no she just
has a different experience of the use of
words that's even better and that is an
excuse that can really get anyone off
the hook
can't it so maybe Carlson can use that
now I want to talk more about the
Carlson thing and I'm going to explain
why I don't care at all what he said I
don't believe he owes anyone an apology
I don't think you should be fired I
don't think you should face any
consequences whatsoever and I want to
explain all that to you but first I'm
gonna tell you about the freedom project
Academy now you know that I'm always on
this show whining about the public
school system but but rightfully
righteously whining righteous whining
that's going to be the name of my
memoirs
one day but I complained about the open
school system and and what people people
always ask me and they'll say well
what's the alternative what's a better
plan and and I say well I don't give
better plans I just I just complain
about the plan that everyone is doing
and then I but I don't I don't I'm not
the solutions guy I'm just the criticism
guy but this time I have a solution and
it's called freedom project Academy we
know that in the school system real
world skills like reading and writing
and arithmetic and all these things
there
replaced by social justice and
indoctrination and this test-driven
instruction we're memorization and
regurgitation are what's required so
that kids become like basically like
mother birds vomiting out information
that was just fed to them but freedom
project Academy is a better choice it is
an accredited classical online school
built on judeo-christian values for
students in kindergarten all the way
through high school Freedom Project
Academy has has taken the interaction of
the traditional classroom and created an
online atmosphere and what happens is
students across the country are
instructed online by live teachers in
small classrooms and the good thing is
they're not it's not that they're that
they're told what to think that they're
told you know what information they have
to regurgitate it's more that they're
taught how to think and taught how to be
critical thinkers which is which is
supposed to be the point of Education
right so go to freedom for school comm
and you can request your free
information packet today that's freedom
for school comm you got enroll by enroll
by March 31st and there all kinds of
discounts and stuff and also don't
forget to subscribe to their weekly
podcast the dr. Duke show available on
iTunes and more take back control of
your kids education freedom for school
comm freedom for school comm freedom for
school calm okay now Tucker Carlson the
fine folks at Media Matters I'm not sure
if fine is really the word I'm
description I'm looking for you could
put in a different description if you
want there but the folks at Media
Matters went and dug up a handful of
clips of Tucker Carlson doing Collins on
a shock jock morning show called Bubba
the Love Sponge and I know it's very
it's very shocking to find out that that
maybe there were some inappropriate
jokes told on the Bubba the Love Sponge
Show you know in the mid-2000s but
that's the case so they found clips from
2006 to 2011 some of this stuff goes
back you know almost 15 years then and
the clips are bad okay bad jokes bad
opinions bad think bad speech let me
play a little little piece of it here
sister where we run into her all the
time she seems like a full yeah they're
very she seems extremely I like that
word oh yeah I'd step over me she seems
why now go ahead
she does seem a little you said it I was
just agreeing with you I don't use that
word right I love for Tucker Carlson
tonight on MSNBC a girl that comes
across product I love women but they're
extremely primitive their basic they're
not that hard to understand
I feel sorry for unattractive women I
mean something they did you know anybody
who answers my trophy wife is my
favorite possession is my hero I don't
you I'm voting for the guy
okay so Carlson uses the c-word he makes
crew jokes about women he makes a joke
about a case of a 20-something year old
teacher having sex with a 13 year old
boy now of course everyone is acting
especially shocked and appalled about
that joke even though approximately four
billion other people and I've counted
have made jokes about those situations
too now this is you know the kind of
thing that everybody jokes about and I
think that they're all bad jokes I don't
agree with them you know if you watch
this show I'm going on about about the
sex abuse problem in the public school
all the time I don't think it's a funny
thing but you know let's not act
surprised here this is just it's the
same thing that almost everyone says
about it and I do think it's interesting
that all of the sudden leftists are so
concerned about the sex abuse problem in
the public school apparently now that
Tucker Carlson has caught making a joke
about it ten years ago thought now all
the sudden they care now it's a very
serious issue
well I've been trying to call attention
to this problem for years and they
didn't care so so you know excuse me if
I just kind of roll my eyes at that so
you know then there are the Carlson also
in talking about the Warren Jeffs
situation he shares some rather edgy
opinions saying among other things that
in arranged marriage between a 16 year
old and a 27 year old isn't the same
thing as rape all right now of course
the left is kicked into full gear
demanding that he be fired demanding
that advertise
dropped the show demanding that he
apologized Carlson for his part so far
has not apologized he issued a statement
yesterday and this is what the statement
said he said Media Matters caught me
saying some something naughty on a radio
show more than a decade ago rather than
Express the usual ritual contrition how
about this I'm on television every
weeknight live for an hour if you want
to know what I think you can watch
anyone who disagrees with my views is
welcome to come on and explain why now
of course that response has just made
the left even more angry personally I
love that response from Carlson and I
hope he sticks with that tack the hope
he doesn't back down I don't care what
the guy said on a radio show 15 years
ago I don't I don't care about his bad
jokes and they were bad no question
about that if my child if it was my son
you know going around using that kind of
language and saying those things he
would be in a lot of trouble I would
certainly be grounded probably for that
but Tucker Carlson is not my son he's a
grown man made bad jokes a long time ago
and I don't care I just don't and I'm
not saying this because it's a Fox News
host either I said the same thing with
Kevin Hart Kevin Hart is not a
conservative and I was I defended Kevin
Hart quite a bit I don't care about
jokes that people told years ago and you
know something neither do you
nobody does you don't I don't nobody
cares nobody cares nobody is actually
offended nobody is traumatized nobody
cried themselves to sleep last night
because Tarka Carlson used a bad word on
the bubble the love sponge show in 2007
nobody did
because nobody cares but some people
pretend that they care they pretend that
they care and then we're supposed to
pretend that they're pretending and I'm
just I'm just done with it and the only
reason they pretend is because they
hated
Elson already in fact if you go to
Twitter right now and you go on the
hashtag fire Tucker Carlson you go click
on that hashtag you're gonna see
thousands of people saying words to the
effect of I always hated Tucker he's
always been a bigot and now we have
proof of it
so what they're admitting is that they
wanted him fired before this so what do
we care if you're saying well fire
Tucker Carlson and then you're admitting
that you always wanted him fired well
then what does your opinion matter if
you're saying you're gonna boycott
Tucker Carlson and then in the next
breath you say that oh you've always
found them to be a disgusting bigot well
then what is it what what is the point
of your boycott that's like if I said
that's like if I said you know we need
to boycott Taco Bell I've always hated
it well you see that the next part after
a boycott Taco Bell kind of undermines
the boycott about it because I my
boycott if I've always hated it then I'm
my boycott doesn't really do much does
it
so they they've always hated them and
then they dig up these bad thoughts that
he shared and they think they got him so
it's all a game in fact I saw someone
say exactly that there was just one one
person on Twitter said slightly
paraphrasing but it says something like
I've always hated them and now we got
him so it's a game is the point and we
should choose not to play the game and
look I'm not going to just acclaim or
I'm not gonna say that we should that we
should never criticize someone for
things that they say but there's got to
be a statute of limitations on this
stuff right and and I don't know exactly
what that statute of limitations is but
it's it's a small window like I don't
know 24 hours 48 hours the point is if
somebody said something and you're gonna
be offended by it you need to make up
your mind quickly okay you can't decide
10 years later that oh you know what
actually I was offended by that you
can't
go back and say oh wait remember that
thing that he said during the Bush
administration yeah you know what
actually I'm really offended and upset
by that Oh boohoo
I'm really really look how offended I am
you see these invisible tears you can't
see them but they're there it's too late
water under the bridge you-you-you had
your chance
okay the outrage train was going through
the station and you missed it by ten
years it's too late now you're gonna
have to wait for the next one
now you might argue that well well well
nobody hurt it back then nobody noticed
nobody cared back then because he wasn't
prominent back then and like he is now
okay fine then it was no harm no foul I
guess if nobody noticed it back then
then then it was just it was it was a
tree falling in the forest and nobody
was there to hear the sound so who cares
if nobody noticed it who cares why does
it matter if anyone is really hurt by
his words now and I don't think anyone
is because of sticks and stones and all
that
sticks and stones words will never hurt
me but but if someone is actually hurt
by these opinions and jokes that he
shared 10 15 years ago it's only because
the left went and dug it up and
broadcast it so that people would be
offended the left is saying hey here's a
great thing to be offended by guys check
it out so I'm just I'm done with it I'm
exhausted by it and it's not going to
stop unless we stop playing along if we
continue to allow ourselves to be
manipulated and we react with the
expected shock and outrage and horror
when smear merges go merchants go
digging for this kind of stuff then it's
going to keep happening and they'll keep
destroying people based on opinions
expressed years ago and jokes that were
made decades ago the only way it stops
the only way this stuff stops is if when
it happens we all react by going
okay don't care when the smear merchants
you know have their treasure trove of
offensive comments that they've dug up
and they come running into the room and
they say hey guys check this out
and we say yeah you know what I don't
feel like getting up but yeah I'll look
at that later really cool stuff good
good job nice job finding that I hope
you know it was a two weeks well-spent
I'm sure combing through every interview
tucker carlson has ever done great job
really well done thumbs up if that's how
we react then this will stop happening
because there's did be no reason to do
it this the famous scene in scripture
where the adulterous woman about to be
stoned to death and Jesus says let he
without sin cast the first stone
that line in Scripture is is often I
think used inappropriately in situations
situations it doesn't apply to that
phrase you know let he without sin cast
the first stone I think is miss applied
often but this kind of situation is
exactly the sort of situation it does
apply to because if you really have
never ever in your life said anything
horrible if you've never told a really
bad offensive joke if you've never gone
off on some tangent expressing some
opinion that you were later embarrassed
by if you've really never done that ever
in your life then go ahead and throw a
stone at Carlson go ahead but but
realize something that one day they're
gonna come for you okay if they never do
it's just because you were never
important enough that no one ever cared
enough but if you ever stick your head
up far enough above the crowd and get a
little attention and you know make some
waves then they're going to go
to try to destroy you and they're gonna
check to see if you're really as clean
and pure as you claim and you definitely
aren't because nobody is and when they
discover that you aren't and they find
whatever bad thing you said and they
ruin your life how are you going to
object you can't because you were part
of the mob yourself and now they've
turned around on you that's that's
that's the way this goes so and that's
why refusing to apologize I think is
really the way to go here and and I
would I would be in favor of doing away
with the public apology genre entirely
or almost entirely I think 90% of the
time if not more the public apology is
completely pointless and there's no
reason for it if you have done something
to actually harm someone whether
physically or emotionally or whatever if
you have really caused harm to an actual
individual person or individual people
then go and apologize to them okay you
don't need to apologize in front of the
entire world we don't need to be witness
to your humiliation we don't need to
witness your regret we don't need the
the ritualistic as Tucker Carlson said
the ritualistic contrition we don't need
that that's pointless nine nine times
out of ten in the public apology
situation the person is apology
apologizing to a public that hasn't been
harmed if target Carlson owes an apology
to anyone I don't think he does
but if he does it's not to the public
you and I weren't harmed by this we
don't care the people who dug this stuff
up they certainly aren't owed an apology
so who is I who cares the whole thing is
is just it's theater is what it is
that's all it's it's simply theater it's
it's performance and the person who
issues the public apology is taking part
in the performance and the rest of us
when we read or listen to the apology
and we talk to each other but I don't
know if he was I don't know if he really
meant it I know of course he didn't mean
it
he was only he was just forced to say
that because he's groveling and he's
trying to rescue his his uh ruined
reputation and career in life that's
also we all know that we all know that
the public apology is not sincere it
never is so why do we demand it it's
completely pointless I think a lot about
the I've mentioned this comparison
before I think but the the play / movie
The Crucible I see so much similarity
between that and our situation today
you know the Salem witch trials where
these people were forced to you know
confess and apologize for being witches
or they'd be hung and there's the great
scene at the end there where John
they're trying to get John Proctor to
you know apologize and confess for being
a witch and he refuses and he says is
there no good penitence but it be public
saying basically why do you need this
whole thing even if you think that I'm a
witch why do you need me why do you need
all this what's the point of this what's
the point of the theatre I'm not gonna
do it and then he was you know huh
fortunately nobody's being hung these
days but but it's it is a less violent
version of that where you've got to do
the whole performance you've got to
apologize or we're gonna take your life
away we're gonna take your career your
reputation all that we simply we have to
be done with it alright a couple other
things so I want
bring this up not quite as important but
a woman was mauled by a Jaguar at a zoo
in Arizona over the weekend and the
Jaguar the Jaguar didn't escape it
wasn't like it got out of the the thing
and it went and attacked her no the
woman climbed over a barrier and went
right next to the big cats cage because
of why do you think she did that you
already know why because she wanted to
take a selfie right and so as she was
taking a selfie the cat reached out his
paw and swiped her had caused a really
nasty gash on her arm
though she's she recovered in the
hospital I think she's gonna be fine it
wasn't life-threatening or anything like
that but this brings me to one of my 6
million pet peeves which is which is you
know and I'm not the first one to
complain about it but okay so you're at
the zoo and you see a Jag water and you
say I want to get a picture of that
Jaguar because that's a cool picture and
you know I'll put it online so that
other people can see this Jaguar well
great you know I mean we've all seen
Jaguars before I don't really think you
need to put the picture online I don't
think you need the picture because I
could always go in Google Images and
look up a picture of a Jaguar I could
probably find a better picture than
whatever one you could take at the zoo
but but that's fine you want to take the
picture fine what why do you need your
face in it though that's my thing what
this thing we do now where every picture
we take we need our own face in it you
see if you're you know you're you're out
on a hike or something and you you're at
a you know you go up on some big cliff
and there's a nice view and there's the
Sun setting and there's a lake down
there there are trees and they're Birds
go by it's just a beautiful view right
now I personally think you don't need to
take a picture of that at all you really
don't need a picture because again
everybody online we've all seen nice
views before and we could find one if we
wanted to through Google Image Search
that's probably better than the one that
you could take so I would say forget
about the picture completely just
experience it you don't need to file it
away in here and in here I mean absorb
it into your self as an experience you
don't need the picture but if
you're gonna take the picture why do you
need your ugly mug in ruining the
picture that's what I don't understand
every single picture now is taken like
this no turn it around and take the
picture this way
just take the picture we know what your
face looks like we don't need it's not
that interesting I'm sorry but in it
ruins every picture it's in so we don't
need it
and this is what happens I mean there
was there was someone who was taking a
selfie I think at the Grand Canyon or
something there's something relatively
recently and fell off it the people are
dying over this selfie obsession and
it's all because of this narcissistic
need we have to put ourselves into
everything and I don't see if I was on a
the one cruise that I've ever been on
with my wife on our honeymoon and and I
I I remember this especially it just
seared into my mind when we were on the
way back one night and there was a it
was an especially beautiful sunset over
the ocean and so everybody was on the
deck looking at the sunset except I say
well I say everyone was looking at the
sunset I was looking at the sunset
everybody else had their back turn to
the sunset so that they could get a
picture of the sunset with their own
face ruining it and everything about
that just we no one needs a picture of a
sunset we've all seen sunsets experience
it and if you really feel the need to
take just take the picture why do you
think your face is going to improve the
Sun it's not going to all right um this
was kind of funny though let's something
a little bit a little bit lighter Alyssa
Milano got herself into trouble with her
with her leftist compatriots over the
weekend when she tweeted this is what
she tweets she was responding to
somebody and I don't know I didn't see
the whole exchange doesn't really matter
but this is what she tweeted she said
I'm trans I'm a person of color I'm an
immigrant I'm a lesbian allows
I'm a gay man I'm the disabled I'm
everything and so are you don't be
afraid of what you don't know or
understand no one wants to hurt you we
are all just looking for our happily
ever after
I'm trans I'm a person of color I'm an
immigrant I'm a chair I'm a table I'm
Wilford Brimley I'm the color blue and
she's everything right she is everything
now of course I saw that that tweet and
I said oh she's gonna get it for this I
heard she wrote that to try to appeal to
the left but you can't do that anymore
I see how did she not know that she was
going to get a lot of backlash for that
and sure enough she did from from all of
as I said her leftist friends who who
said well I I we appreciate you're
trying to be an ally but that but you
don't appropriate people or claim
identities that don't belong to you as a
way to relate to us and so she was being
scold and scolded left and right for
that but it's kind of interesting
because this sort of thing this is
exactly the kind of faux spiritual
pantheistic new-agey gibberish that even
as recently as ten years ago probably
would have been applauded by by everyone
on the left that's exactly the kind of
thing that ten or fifteen years ago
people would have loved and they would
have ate it up but but now identity
politics have gotten to a point where
you can't even do the faux spiritual
pantheistic gibberish anymore which is
really a shame because i kind of
preferred that i preferred that version
of liberalism over what we have now
because at least that version was kind
of funny right but this new thing is not
nearly as charming in my mind speaking
of identity politics I want to move on
to emails you can always email the show
at Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt wall
show at gmail.com this is from jasmine
she says Matt gosh I was so thankful for
the clarification you gave in the
victimization flowchart my sister and I
have often
in a survival survivor style Show
Starring all victimized classes who
would win this explains so much we
obviously knew that white men are the
first voted off the island but the
subsequent steps were enlightening
question though what happens when
someone holds to victimize class cards
jussie Smollett for example black and
homosexual and the special card of
Hollywood how did he not automatically
win the whole game we've often wondered
in the season finale between a Muslim
woman and a black lesbian who wins
anywho super thankful for you and your
efforts pray for you and your family
often keep up the good work I'm sure it
gets discouraging often hi Jasmine if
you if you missed the show anyone who
missed the show on Friday I went over
the left's victimization flowchart and
in fact it's this is nice because a
listener by the name of Billy Park was
kind enough to convert my victimization
flowchart into a graphic into a handy
graphic for so we can all kind of see it
Illustrated so I'll put it up on the
screen take a look at this if you're
watching on YouTube right now you can
see it so as you can see the
victimization flows down right each
group can only be victimized by the
group's above it so white men are at the
very top victimized by no one and you
can see there the victimhood scale on
the side which which measures victim
points so white men have no victim
points actually have negative victim
points while non-white transgenders have
the most so you see it there and
hopefully this answers your question
jasmine because as you could see
non-white gay men do measure solid 60 or
70 on the victimhood scale but they are
not they are not the most they're not
the victimized victims at all there are
there are three or four steps above them
and remember this is victim Vic this is
the most important thing to remember for
identity politics is that victimization
always flows down it is as I said on
Friday it's like a waterfall and so you
can never reverse the flow white men are
at the top all of that is really the
source of all victimization and it flows
down from there but other groups can be
guilty of victimizing as well but they
can only
demise down right so your victimization
goes down your source of victimhood
comes from above right so that's that's
the way that it works all right
this is from Lisa says hey Matt in your
Friday in your episode on Friday you
mentioned God is love in regards to a
certain topic but it got me thinking a
common mantra in society is love is love
but I thought God is love does this mean
our society's essentially saying love is
God I believe I already know the answer
but thought this was interesting and it
would love your take thanks Lisa hi
least I think that's an excellent
insight we have flipped it on its head
haven't we we go from God is love to
love is love to love is God
and there is a big difference between
God is love and love is love if this is
not like a two equals two type of thing
so God is love yes but love is not God
and if love is God then what we really
mean to say is that our experience of
love our feeling our personal subjective
feeling of what we call love is God
is final is ultimate it is the guiding
principle upon which we base everything
so really it goes like this
god is love okay if that's not the case
that love is love no love is God no I am
God that's kind of that's the genesis
right if of is God then I as the
experiencer of love the one the one
that's conjuring it that's making it
than I am God and and this is one of the
reasons by the way why why I think the
phrase God is love can be confusing even
though I use that phrase myself
apparently I don't remember using it but
I guess I did and it's true that that
God is love but I think it gets
confusing and it may just be better and
easier and clearer to say rather than
saying God is love just say God is loves
source or
even more simply God is loving God is
perfectly loving doesn't mean exactly
the same thing but it gets the idea
across because right when you say God is
love then it sounds like you could flip
that around and love is God let's see
this is from Courtney it's ladies night
if you can't tell on the mat walls show
all these emails are from women so if
anyone ever accuses me of me of being
sexist again I can always say I'm not
sexist I answer emails from women so it
says from Courtney says hi Matt I know I
think I know your opinion on
recreational marijuana but what is your
opinion on medical marijuana should it
be legalized well Courtney if you know
my opinion on the legalization of
recreational weed then that makes one of
us because I don't really know where I
stand on that it depends on the week
really or the day or depends on which
argument I've just read because I am
easily slave swayed back and forth on
this I am a flip-flopper on this issue
which if I could just say one thing
about that you know we criticize people
who are flip-floppers all the time and
often for good reason because especially
for politicians what what flip-flop
really means is that they change their
opinion to suit the situation or to suit
the crowd or whatever so it's really
just another way of saying that they are
hypocritical and opportunistic but
there's also some amount of
flip-flopping as human beings that's
pretty natural isn't it and I fully
admit there are some issues where I kind
of vacillate between different positions
that I'm very susceptible to a good
argument from either side and so I'll
hear an argument and I'll say yeah you
know I think you're right about that and
then some will make it someone will make
an opposite argument and I'll say yeah
you know what maybe you're right about
that because there are issues that I
just I don't care that much about so I
don't spend a lot of time researching
them and I simply can't make up my mind
I think that's normal I mean it's normal
to for people to be like it's not like
we we set all of our opinions on every
topic and they're set in stone and
they'll never change it's just that's
what they are at least if we're critical
thinkers that's not the way it should be
so
yeah so medical recreational marijuana
you know there are arguments on both
sides I don't know
medical marijuana though is something
that I'm much more firm on that I'm not
very susceptible I absolutely definitely
support medical marijuana and I think
that the arguments against I don't even
know what the arguments could be III do
know I've heard the arguments but it's
just to oppose it is is simply not just
wrong but inhumane and cruel and stupid
if somebody has stage four cancer and
marijuana dulls the pain then great what
kind of person would argue against that
how could anyone go to someone who's
dying of stage four cancer and say yeah
the marijuana dulls the pain it makes
your life at least somewhat bearable but
I heard it makes me uncomfortable if
you're using marijuana so you shouldn't
be able to do it I there's just it's
it's crazy when it comes to painkillers
marijuana is definitely a 100 times
safer than than many other forms of
painkillers
you take oxycontin or for instance
people are prescribed oxycontin after a
back injury or something and the next
thing you know they're heroin addicts
and it really does work that way and
this is why we have everyone's wondering
why do we have all these normal
middle-class soccer moms now or becoming
drug addicts and the answer is because
of these prescription prescription pills
it's because we're prescribing heroin
through them basically and so yeah I
think medical marijuana is preferable to
that absolutely this is from Megan I
thought this was an interesting one she
says hey Matt I was wondering what you
thought about fathers participating in
dangerous activities especially ones
with high rates of serious injury
according to statistics quoted here from
the National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration there are between eighty
eight thousand and one hundred thousand
injuries and five thousand fatalities
per year from motorcycle
Asha's as an EMT I have personally cared
for motorcycle crash patients and those
who do survive are often left with
devastating traumatic brain injuries
that leave them severely disabled
saddest of all these patients are
usually young men between 18 and 45 and
many of these men have children I
understand that the soul of a man crack
craves adventure I have heard from many
of my male friends how alive and free
they feel on a motorcycle and that in
itself is a good thing however is it
morally okay for fathers to risk death
or serious injury unnecessarily doesn't
a father have an obligation to do
everything in his power to protect his
life that his health when his spouse and
children depend on him what are your
thoughts on this the question goes
beyond riding a motorcycle but also
statistically proven dangerous
activities like MMA boxing budget
jumping et cetera god bless you and your
family hi Megan I think it's a very
intriguing question and you've hit on
something important here because there's
this balance that you need on one hand a
man does crave adventure in danger like
you said and it would be a bad thing for
a wife or when he's younger a mother to
completely stifle that out of fear you
can't try to nag that out of a man
because if you do that all you're all
you'll succeed in is getting him to
suppress it for a time until eventually
he finds an outlet that may ultimately
be a whole lot worse than what it would
have been before that so that's not a
that's not a it's not a in itself a bad
desire and instinct in men it's a good
thing on the other hand it's true that a
married man has a responsibility to his
family so for him to go and risk his
life unnecessarily recreationally in a
reckless way well I think that that is
probably selfish because he's basically
saying that his desire for adventure and
excitement it completely supersedes
his children's need for a father and his
wife's need for a husband of course it's
different if we're talking about a
profession right like there are some
professions police officer firefighter
where those are dangerous jobs but in
that case it's it's his job it's his
duty and also he's providing something
for his family in doing it and not just
money but also the example of heroism
and selflessness and courage is a great
is something he's giving to his family
as well so we're not talking about that
we're talking about recreational things
I assume yeah where do you draw the line
there is it immoral to ride a motorcycle
I I would say no I don't know a lot
about motorcycles but it strikes me that
motorcycles can be operated safely right
or relatively safely I'm guessing you
would know more than me as an EMT but
I'm guessing that many of the bad
motorcycle accidents that you see
probably involve people on motorcycles
doing very reckless things aside from
just riding the motorcycle the first
place like when you see these guys on
motorcycles going 90 miles an hour
riding down the middle of the highway in
between lanes well that's Jess I mean
that's that's verging on suicidal to do
something like that and I think that's
part of what makes motorcycles dangerous
is that they encourage you to behave
recklessly like that because you can do
things like right in between lanes and
we even and out of traffic and stuff
like that but if you don't do that and
you you're being responsible then I
think you know I I don't see it as
inherently reckless simply to get on a
motorcycle but I you know I think that
there are other recreational activities
that you would that maybe would be ruled
out like I don't know BASE jumping or
something when you jump off a cliff with
a parachute stuff like that you know I
think yeah so there is a balance I don't
know exactly where it is but I do think
it's something that that you need to
think about that that men need to think
about and the last thing I'll say is
this this is part of what a father is
post is a very important aspect of what
the father does for us children
including especially a son which I think
isn't talked about enough but this is
why boys need fathers to show them how
to take risks safely and in ways that
are not reckless because boys are going
to have that urge to go out and be rowdy
and roughhouse and you know it find
adventure and so they need their dads
there to show them how to do that and
you know take them out to climb the tree
and to do these things that are a little
bit dangerous but in a safe way and so
that they have that safe responsible
outlet for that and that's something
that fathers you know do for their for
their kids and not just physical risks
either because this is about risk-taking
and teaching kids how to take risks
responsibly but there are there are
other kinds of risks that I think kids
need to be taught how to take
intellectual risks you know emotional
risks even going out on a limb and
voicing your opinion taking a stand
those are risks as well and I think that
also is an example that fathers should
provide for their children all right but
thanks for the email thanks for the
emails everyone matt walsh o @ gmail.com
if anyone else wants to send in and
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
Godspeed